easily one of my favorite episodes of
daily be this lunch got into some real
insights some different thinking and
some really powerful stuff here in
Toronto so hope you enjoyed you these
daily be oxygen to me it's how
everything works you know and if you do
it great you're getting people to do
things for the right reasons you know
and that's cool branding and propaganda
can get very close right and that's why
I throw in for the right reasons cuz
that's long term but to me it's not
being at the mercy of anybody I think
what I like about my life is I'm not at
the mercy of anybody and a lot of that
has to do with branding and just my own
kind of like lack of expectation of
others which makes it all upside which
is good so I think it's I think to me
that's what's been so interesting about
the auto industry is technology has
stepped right in the middle of you and
the unconsumed in a meaningful way and
they have the leverage the amount of
referral business that goes on in this
world amount of money dealerships pay
for referrals in one shape or form
is a bad macro economic structure it's
not only is it unbelievably expensive
the refers are being kind to you still
they have all the leverage Apple one day
decided it was 30 percent big on the app
right that you know if you guys know
what goes on the Apple world like when
you transact there Apple's biggest 30
percent you know crazy that's a big
number you know if one player in the
referral business decides to double the
fee because they can afford to
they'll all be double and you're gonna
do nothing about it you have no leverage
brand is the only thing that can stop
that got it brands the one thing that
goes from utility to emotional
so I have a quick question about it goes
along with branding but like so hard
you'll agree we have 12 source and not
all of them are named the same over our
name is foul and we're trying to brand
the name fat and get the name out there
we have a Porsche dealership with their
dealership some luxury high-end
dealerships what is more important to
focus on the Porsche name and clear name
or to keep branding as fast and get that
name out there it's not even close it's
it's not even a close to mate it's so
much if it's so much of it's so
important that if it was my family
business and I looked at the contracts
and there was a way for us to fire
somebody not doing it and they were the
biggest economic driver I would spend
all my life convincing my dad we had to
fire them that's how much of an abyss
you should do whatever you think is
right Jamie but it's hot if you're if I
was part of the business and I had say
it would be the only thing I care about
it's the answer that I just gave the
gentleman there it's the only thing I
would get the only brother it's the only
thing you got it's the only thing you
have it doesn't feel like that right
that doesn't win the sprint Porsche wins
the sprint that's wins the marathon
that we were having the same
conversation I actually I said opposite
I get it fine so because you're right
about that
but you're just not playing out the
chests of it all okay sure in four years
when Porsche sends you an email and says
you've got 18 months and we're out
you're gonna be like [ __ ] but Jamie on
that note guys I'm gonna say it I want
to make sure you understand it Nintendo
was a plain card company Nintendo
started as a playing card company I
shirt off as a wine merchant like I get
it but I actually usually think the
number one move when [ __ ] is interesting
is to leverage while you've got it the
building of the other thing with the
assumption that the first thing might
not even be there at all and then taking
it all as upside and then you can get
smart right like so the way to get to
the orange is kind of silly lawn mowers
a little bit closer but what about why
can't you guys start the coolest air
refreshment thing in a car company out
of your little one-stop like why
couldn't somebody here create the $10
premium air refresher you know I just
think of this like I don't know if
people think you know like why not you
could and you'd have pretty much as much
permission to do it as anybody else I'll
go I'll go a different place with you I
think that BMW and Porsche and Mercedes
should be going into other sectors I'll
go the reverse I think if I met Mercedes
I'm the CEO I would be creating an Alexa
Google home Apple home pod competitor
because I permissioned because of my
brand to be behind engineering and high
quality product I would
why should bran be the biggest racer in
the world like I would buy BMWs Razer so
you know you got to think about where
you have permission to hedge
doing stuff like that like making
bicycles and making this make it make
sense yeah that's cool know what I stole
Harley Davidson that's right try
anything that's branded Harley Davidson
because Harley Davidson really built a
brand they went they whoever was running
I know nothing but like whoever was
running that ship and that probably that
era they went all the way they actually
I actually think they went too far I
think of Harley Davidson similar to
Playboy I think sometimes you [ __ ] out
your name so much that you dilute it so
you have to be careful 60% of our sales
which by the way may be great like you
know it's funny sometimes you look at
margin you know my dad's business I'm
trying to convert Wine Library it's
called Wine Library I'm trying to get my
dad to basically become a food store you
know I'm not a scholar I didn't go to
Yale and did a couple studies and I'm a
good public speaker and wrote a book and
we're having this conversation
I do what you do I there's never been a
day since I would from the the day I
left college at 22 I drove from Boston
to New York to New Jersey to home and
from four I got there for 18 and worked
from the for 18 to 7:30 before me and my
dad went home this is the day I left
college from that moment on to the
second I'm sitting here right now I have
never not operated as a CEO a business
in my life even in the transition
between Wine Library and the building of
garyvee I was the CEO vaynermedia yes I
was a little more passive than AJ was
but it wouldn't be there without me so
I'm a you know I I don't say this stuff
in theory it's not theory for me this is
not intellectual this is practical
reality I think in the way I communicate
it feels hyperbolized cuz I'm a showman
but now I'm an interesting part of my
career cuz now I have some history
behind me that makes it a little it's a
little harder to completely laugh me off
the stage you know because you keep
winning that much it's hard that's why I
built vaynermedia Madison Avenue tough
place big companies holding companies
billion-dollar companies he's just a
Twitter kid everybody made fun I the
articles are in the Internet Twitter boy
thinks he can win Madison Avenue this
[ __ ] kid he didn't things say that
this guy thinks no that's what they
wanted to say this guy thinks he's a big
shot it's a lot harder to build a
Madison Avenue agency is them to get
some Twitter followers vaynermedia is
the fastest
growing organic top-line revenue agency
in the history of the business seven
years $150,000,000 no ma all organic no
cash infusion that doesn't happen
because I'm charismatic that happens
because I operate communication
communication David you know day trading
day trading communication if my wife
text me right now and she's like [ __ ]
this I won't go to Chicago right now
I'll fly home and then I'll talk until
it's not [ __ ] this now a lot of it was
back to making good strategies like I
had a young age knew who I needed to
marry I I didn't know it you know us
guys and we're mainly guys here when
you're younger you're like you want your
girl to be obsessed with you this I
didn't realize how desperately I needed
to marry somebody who was super
independent and had her own [ __ ] and was
her you know that's funny to me in
hindsight of the teenage me would have
never thought that right somewhere super
her own person and she's a stay-at-home
mom but from a framework she doesn't
need me you know kind of which is
interesting and then an extremism so
Monday through Friday when I'm on the
field it's 7:00 a.m. to midnight and
then in the weekends I'm completely
completely checked out at home and I
take seven full weeks of vacation
completely checked out and I said
extremism something that won't work for
most yeah you know you don't know what's
going on in somebody's bedroom right but
I don't let any I'll tell you how I rely
leave you another answer the maybe even
more important in communication I'm just
not interested in your guy's opinion on
my parenting style too many people are
pandering to the current state of
political correctness of parenting
right that's right everybody and I'm
empathetic to it I get it but I actually
I actually on the record of this I do
believe this co-parenting this concept
will be looked upon in a hundred years
from now as wrong I'm not believing two
cooks in the kitchen there's no such
thing as co-ceos or him I think I think
in I think in 70 years I think people
are gonna get if I think it's 70 years I
think we all know couples where when you
look at their DNA the woman or the man
should be at work the woman or the man
should be at home so I think we went
through woman at home man
now we're living through another you
know starting to get into like a
co-parenting thing and we'll do this for
another 20-30 years I think our kids and
probably more likely our grandkids are
gonna be really smart and awed it with
each other and be like you're higher you
have a higher capacity to earn I have a
higher capacity to nurture and then
let's go because boy I know ten couples
where the woman's at home and she's 50
[ __ ] times more capable than the guy
and and I know equally as many couples
worth she's a disaster and not nurturing
at all and he's the most lovely thing of
all time I think that's going to be the
future of parenting I think so I think
it's practical Bon Appetit
um my biggest miss is definitely the
things that I haven't done so I don't
know him in detail cuz that's my biggest
issue crippled by opportunity right the
biggest missus black and white are I was
super right about YouTube a company
called viddler came along and gave me
seven percent of their company to move
my Wine Library show to viddler and I
stopped producing for YouTube up until a
year and a half ago and I left ungodly
amounts of branding on the table over
the last decade I passed on uber z'
angel round twice if you guys go take
out a library crush at my first book I
had only acknowledged one person and my
acknowledgments besides my parents my
family and that's Travis the CEO of uber
cuz he's a dear friend of mine and I
passed on a friend of Mines company
twice and it ended up being over so
that's pretty black-and-white I didn't I
didn't answer the email that reads like
this hey Gary we were huge fans we
desperately want you to invest in our
company we'd love to have a meeting
didn't even reply to the email that came
from Airbnb so I'm real I mean I was so
right that I have such real losses you
know cuz you couldn't get them all right
I don't have I don't have the losses I
don't know losses that most people have
because I've never done anything
financially that could hurt me really
bad I'm stunned by people's ability to
do things that can put you out of
business like overextending yourself I
don't do that no I'm not if I don't have
the cash I don't do that I'm willing to
borrow I mean I got a lease at Hudson
Yards that scares the [ __ ] out of me
right but those are a little more
calculated I want two biggest reasons I
built my personal brand is I used Gary
Vee as an insurance policy for my life
like if all else fails I can make twenty
million dollars you're speaking and
writing books that's the most ridiculous
thing I've ever said in my life but it's
true and it's and it's and it's awesome
you know so I think I did that but I
also did it for branding vaynermedia
doesn't pick do our fees we're just last
week five of the biggest 500 businesses
in the
called me directly and said will you
take our business that's called brand
you know so we don't have a sales team
we don't have a head of new business and
we're the fastest-growing efforts
bring them let the market come to you
the person that asks gives up the
leverage right sales that's why it's
hard the way I knew the internet was
gonna be big the way new e-commerce the
way email and Google AdWords I was
building patter you know by not being
educated by not knowing rich people I
came from like a very funny place I
don't I didn't know a lot of stuff I
didn't even know venture capital existed
so I'm like wait a minute like this is
interesting I'm good at things like this
is not a joke I'm like I understand I'm
not a good salesman I'm not a good wine
merchant I'm good at things like that's
how I think so I started reading
everything about YouTube selling for two
billion dollars and I don't know if you
guys remember when YouTube sold for two
billion
it was 1.7 it was in two thousand seven
or eight I don't remember exactly but if
you remember that was like a trillion
dollars at the time remember that was
like now we throw around a billion right
good I'm glad you guys remembered for
kids that you know they came that was
like a trillion
so that's a trillions a lot like if I
woke up this morning and snapchat sold
four trillion or something else over I'd
be like well that's a lot so it hit me
that hard and it was something that I
understood as one of the first 50,000
people to ever understand something
there's something in that in that
bigging I read about angel investors
then I googled angel investor so that's
why I always give this advice I'm not
like and I'm like oh you can invest in
companies like I'm being serious with
you this may sound like there's certain
things I'm good at there's some things
I'm not before they go on the stock
market then I started really getting
into tech but I was like this is gonna
eat the world I'm like that's what I
basically buy narrowly overnight decided
everything that's happening now will
basically eat up everything everything
and so I started really learning I
started reading TechCrunch every day and
then I went to South by Southwest at
2007 and at that South by Southwest 2008
Twitter was exploding and everybody was
[ __ ] on it even the tech kids like
who cares if you because it was
psychology it wasn't utility everybody
was like who cares you know everything
you'd have real tech people the people
that now you all know like very famous
and then something you know but but they
would sit here and I would be up at the
barbecue pit
I'm listening right for all my talking
and I'm doing a lot of it today I listen
all the time and I'm listening and
they're like who gives a [ __ ] if you
walk the dog this is stupid
nobody's gonna care that you're eating
pizza and I'm sitting there and I'm like
everybody's gonna care I'm like that's
what we do that's what life is we don't
want to admit it so that's what I'm good
at right
I knew that everybody was gonna put
their credit card into a computer when
everybody told me they wouldn't I knew
that every I I knew everybody was a
hundred every one of you is gonna retina
scan everything because it's gonna save
you time I knew I knew that everybody
was gonna online date when everybody
thought it was the weirdest [ __ ] ever in
2000 it's just time arbitrage it will be
the thing we trade on every time I get
an email from Dave Moore in the head of
platform and says mark would love for
you to come and speak to the company
about why you believe this I said I'll
be there tomorrow I flew out to Palo
Alto I spoke in front of the company
when it was the size of this conference
I just gave I only spoke about consumer
behavior because at that point I thought
that there was something weird about
Facebook that they really were doing
what I would do if I knew how to do that
so I went weird it was the first time
I'd ever spoken I don't even know how to
articulate it right I didn't know mark
was there he sat all the way in the back
slouched came down goes do you want to
have dinner tonight I said I sure do we
had dinner he was one of the only people
I've ever met in my life that I thought
had the same intuitive understand
about people as I do which is super
funny to me because the way he's
portrayed in the movie is super hot like
he's so not he's introverted in some
ways but in a macro he's all time we
became friendly he would come to New
York a bunch and I would see him which
was gonna be great stories one day to
tell my grandkids and one day his sister
called me Randy and said our parents
mark and i's parents want to sell a
bunch of stock to buy a house and we'd
really like you to be part of the family
would you like to buy some stock and I
said I sure do I was in the back of a
taxi in Miami I'll never forget that
moment whole life I put in every dollar
I had in my bank account except for a
hundred thousand dollars and I'm not
sold one share since thank you thanks
for having me it was really nice being
you guys yeah I'm good daddy take care
of who's your favorite insight your
favorite new insight from today's
episode
[Music]
you
[Music]